turn your great idea into a reality with
Squarespace they make it easier than
ever to launch your passion project
whether you're showcasing your work or
selling products of any kind they have
beautiful templates and the ability to
customize just about anything you can
easily make a beautiful website by
yourself but if you get stuck
Squarespace is 24/7 award-winning
customer support is there to help
head to squarespace.com slash Grace for
a free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace to save
10% off your first purchase of the
website or domain welcome not too deep
I'm your host grace Helbig today we have
Dan levy on the podcast not the guy from
shits Creek not the composers not the
son of Eugene Levy it's dan levy you
might know him from his MTV Veejay
engaging a quatorze you might know him
as the creator and executive producer of
the new show indebted starring Fran
Drescher
Adam pally amongst other amazing cast
members we talk a lot about his
obsession with HGTV
we talk a lot about the the college
shows that he blew the most and some of
his successes along the way and what
it's like to be a parent also I learned
a lot about spider bites it's a very
informative episode all across the board
so enjoy this episode of not too deep
with Dan levy we're rollin we're goin
were you on Jeopardy last year no you
weren't on your IMDB it is yeah it says
on your IMDB under self credits okay
jeopardy himself contestant I definitely
I can all right well I'm gonna email mr.
IMDB and there's so many cause a
complaint there's so many dan dan levees
you know there's yeah look there's that
guy Dan there's a podcaster there's two
composers a composer Scott navigator
Oscar there's Dan levy clean up shits
Creek I mean there's so many of us out
there have you guys created a support
group oh yeah we meet on Wednesdays for
like you know what how is it going
for you Dan levy you can let me have but
do you dare levy and we all get together
very fun yes I'll just commiserate about
the highs and lows of who got confused
for who this week so okay I want first
congratulations indebted thank you so
much
very cool how much can I mean you just
wrapped right yeah we wrapped December
20th so and editing since then okay and
it premieres in February February 6th
after Will and Grace
that's very excited you know I can't
believe it so how did this all come
about and for those that don't know can
you give us the premise of that yes the
premise is essentially when baby boomers
go broke and move back in with their
kids who have kids of their own yes so
it's loosely based on my life okay my
parents are baby boomers who were not
super financially responsible okay they
don't live with me technically but they
visit me 45 times a year and I'm waiting
for me to give them the keys gotcha okay
so they haven't had the keys yet that's
your boundary that's my that's my one
boundary yeah
so you wrote this you created the show
yes I created the show okay did you have
to get any permission from your parents
to write something that's semi
autobiographical yes I asked them and
they said of course my parents are all
in they are yes that's very sweet and
the cast is incredible cast is insane
Fran Drescher plays version of my mom I
secretly wish she played every character
she's an icon she's amazing she's she's
incredible she's a grace is very lovely
she's lovely she's likable she's
everything you want her to be yeah I'm
in Adam pally who is super [ __ ] funny
yeah Abby Elliott amazing great very
funny Jesse Hodge is also hilarious and
of course Steven Weber so you know it's
it's an amazing amazing cast that's so
awesome
how was the shooting process the
shooting process was was great I mean
it's intense because it's a multi-camera
so in front of live audience right so
you're basically doing like for people
that don't know when you do multi camera
isn't it like doing like a play exactly
it's like doing a play it's like almost
similar to like SNL where
you know every Friday night we are
filming front of live audience so we
have the whole week to get it ready and
what happens is on Monday you table read
and then you get notes and you rewrite
it and then Tuesday you do a rehearsal
in front of the producers the writers
and the studio get notes we rewrite it
then Wednesday the network comes we get
notes again we write it then Thursday we
start shooting pre shoots where which
means is you essentially shoot like the
scenes that you can't do in front of an
audience whether it's like a car scene
or an outside scene and then Friday they
rehearse and then we shoot it live Wow
so it's a really intense process because
normally like on other scene cameras
shows I've worked on like the Goldbergs
you basically are writing the show and
then you do a table read on Monday and
then you have the whole week to rewrite
it and then you shoot it so you don't
even really see the actors as much but
you know what's kind of cool about a
multi-campus really becomes like a
family because we're with these people
every single day yeah you're really in
an incubator for this and the writers
are with each other every single night
till late hours Wow so it's it's intense
but it's really fun and you know my
background a stand-up so doing doing a
live comedy show from the audience so
fun because then we change it on the
floor you know so if we want to change
jokes so you're just constantly tweaking
it basically up until the very last
moment yeah just yeah
until we're in take ever take will be
like now the change now say this and
luckily the cast says amazing yeah you
know improv skills yeah you know Fran
and Steven worked on you know
collectively I think like 360 multi cam
episodes just between wings The Nanny so
everyone was great and we'd made a lot
changes on the floor
that's cool yeah what's it like shooting
in front of a live audience because do
they they well this is the first season
of the show they don't know what they're
about to watch they don't they're not
totally invested in these characters yet
so they're just kind of going in a
little blind I assume yeah well what we
do in front of a live audience is we
always play the pilot and we also play a
video of my actual parents yeah
answering questions about their life and
about how much they love me so that's
like a really big part of the show is
how
obsessed my mom is with me no matter
what do you have siblings I do I have a
brother but even my brother's wife was
like my take away your family's your mom
because I'm nicer to my mom they're my
brother yeah you show her more attention
yeah exactly
you celebrate and glorify her legacy in
your art yeah my mom like my mom just
makes everything about me and it's
always like very positive and and that's
sort of what the show is like it's a
very sort of like positive like you know
comedy where these people are in a bad
situation yet they are so confident and
positive with their life yeah that like
it doesn't really bother them the way it
should like most people spiral to
depression we do a whole episode about
how you know Adams character and Abi's
Karen Jesse are sort of obsessed with
social media like we all are
we were always looking at other people's
lives and judging them and and and
wishing that you were in their live on
their vacation wherever is yeah and we
do a whole episode where friends like I
understand what you care yeah but don't
you ever want to be where other people
are and she's like no cuz wherever I am
it's the best Wow that's sort of what
but what's that line something like I
forget the exact line but it was like
mom Fran says like why are you liking
other people's things in Karen people
are doing and then Adams like because
that's what people do we have been
programmed to carry other people's thing
it's like gosh but what a refreshing
point of view exactly do you as yourself
get into social media you don't tweet I
don't tweet because here's the thing I
love Instagram stories yeah dan levy
show but I I was real I liked Twitter
you know back in the day when his joke
you got out which I'm like kudos to you
I took off my phone good because
basically what was happening is every
time I actually like seen people on
vacation like that kind of stuff
Instagram to me is fun because it's more
like look at my life yeah this is a good
things it's a little yeah it's I like to
try and think it I think of it as like
positive voyeurism yes where Twitter is
just like [ __ ] every
oh my god every time I go on Twitter is
like murder
like I don't deal with all of this is
begging you to bring it some of your
like positive optimism so it can just
[ __ ] flatten you out I'm like I go
I'm trending I'm like please please no
and no tragedy no tragedy a tragedy it's
just it's it's I can't I can't deal so I
think though I thought it'd be funny to
go back on Twitter like next week and be
like I'm on Twitter promoting my show
just basically it's like opening a
closet throwing something into it and
then closing the door before anything
comes out yeah it's it's too crazy but
you like Instagram love Instagram who's
your who do you follow do you have like
guilty pleasure follows like oh I'm
currently following old Jewish men okay
and I follow like upscale hype you know
a lot of bass players wardrobe you know
that guy okay okay there's a spectrum
yeah so okay now you're in
post-production for the show yes now
what what's this like you're basically
in like a weird purgatory before it like
actually comes out right yeah it's very
weird because I went from like being
surrounded by like 500 people every day
all day long you know just like a
million questions constantly to then
everyone it's over except for me in the
editor so now it's just like me in the
editor and just sort of cutting the show
and you know just like in your isolation
chamber yeah yeah the tcas way I go to
New York this week I'm doing fun
podcasts like this now but yeah it's
just a weird a weird zone to be in geez
but that's very exciting so then you
have like an actual product that kind of
goes on television yes parents are part
of it it's like it's the whole thing my
wife - your wife yeah my wife writes in
the show amazing you know the characters
based on our relationship - so yeah it's
how long have you guys been together
almost 10 years congratulations yes and
you have two kids two kids two kids yeah
so it feels like you write a lot of from
like your personal life yes exactly
do the kids understand what you do oh
yeah no no they do is how old are they
I'm seven and five okay yeah so now they
do like they come to said and they know
that
there's like little kids who play
versions of them a little and they're
like it's not really our names and I'm
like yeah I know I don't want to do that
no but it is weird because I grew up in
Stamford Connecticut you know with like
no show business background all like my
daddy yeah I see on TV a Salesman and my
mom was like you know an education so
for my kids to grow up like knowing
about like the sets and you know be like
let's go to the stage 23 and see the
Goldberg set it's so foreign thing from
how you grew I know so how do you do you
have any rules or regulations with your
kids in terms of like how much they're
allowed to indulge in social media or
the entertainment industry like do they
come to you and say they want to act or
write or be anywhere involved in this
world well my son wants to be a magician
okay so it's kind of cool yeah one of my
really good friends and old roommates
Justin Willman you know magic for humans
yeah so you know he's hung out with him
a lot but but yeah like I um I don't
wouldn't want them necessarily to be
like child actors just because it's it's
hard and honestly you know running a
show and having kids on the show it's
it's just like yeah it's just hard so
just very hard yeah yeah and it's kind
of I mean it's probably refreshing for
them to do something outside of this
world yeah I know what it's like to be
in this do you have boundaries in terms
of how much of your personal life you
bring into the writing and creating and
content side of stuff not really okay
pretty much just write whatever is funny
which about my life so it's really it's
been that way since I was like you know
write what you know I would I know yeah
yeah how did you get started if your
parents were you know you know more
traditional East Coast jobs or whatever
how did you get started in like
entertainment and comedy when I was nine
I started doing improv at a place called
curtain call no I know someone I did see
someone did tweet that said ask you
about curtain call so yeah there was a
theater theater company in Stamford
Connecticut called curtain call and
I was really sort of like I don't know
what was going on when I was like in
fourth grade but I was I had like had a
lot of confidence and self-esteem I just
you know it's one of those things where
I remember like my mom was like we love
your birthday and I was like everyone
likes Genesis so I want Genesis and then
I got it I was like video games I don't
like sports so I didn't really know what
to do what you know in Connecticut
that's really your options yeah I like
playing the woods and well this weird
thing opened up called improv do that so
I start doing improv when I was like
nine and then I was like I kind of like
found my people yeah and basically just
did like you know drama club and all
that stuff and I was in a comedy called
the half-pint players that kurtik all
cute and we would go into New York and
it was just like that's fine oh and and
then basically I knew from then that I
wanted to like just do stand-up I was
obsessed with ain't evening improv oh
that's with Caroline's Comedy Hour
you know in living color like all that
stuff yeah I was just wanted so bad so
when I when it's going Boston mm-hmm day
one I was like just hitting up mics and
I basically just did stand-up like
through it and then started touring once
I left Boston and then came to LA and
then Wow yeah so you knew I mean kudos
to your mom for suggesting that place
it's such a yeah I was very sort of
focused and then that was really all I
did like I graduate did these things
called NACA tours you know now yeah you
heard of her people that don't know NACA
my understanding of it it's basically
like a convention of sorts where you go
and pimp yourself out it's like a
comedian and colleges can hire you based
on their like student funds there's like
a trade show so you basically go and you
like go I mean when I was doing it you
know I was I was like 22 or something
when I was doing those and I'd come out
and be like and they like just come like
shake your hand hug you and they book
you isn't it like
it's college students that are booking
his college students are booking you
ants their funds and it's honestly like
the best way to make a living when
you're up-and-coming comedian because
pretty well it's really well and you
know at that time your expenses are like
sneakers yeah they're like traveling you
write oh yeah so you would just you know
so I did I mean I like hit like a
million miles in American Airlines but I
was like 28 or something do you have any
memories of colleges that stood out to
perform at for better or worse oh well I
did Gator growl University of Florida
was that huge show I've heard nightmares
about this show well it was actually
awesome okay because it was it was a
great show I think it was it was Kevin
Hart is he's Ansari me oh cool and it
was just joint Stadium it's Florida
Florida Florida goes crazy and basic
come out you're like [ __ ] Florida State
and they're like a gigantic league arena
that takes forever to do go through
jokes this is like applause and
screaming so it's like so ridiculous
that was super fun and then I did so
many terrible colleges there was a there
was a college I did I think the South
East NACA which is like the southeast of
America yeah and like the Florida the
South Carolina all those places and I
did a show at a college called High
Point she drove me and I was like this
is the low point of my comedy here
because it was how ironic so the show
was like fine but afterwards this I
forget the guys name you had this
terrible name and he was he was this
awful person and he was like we don't we
do like the comedy yeah and he was like
in charge of the students he was one of
those weird jobs were like he was in
charge of the students who were in
charge of the money he was like what was
his name and gave you this job like if
you get this position his name wasn't
skull but like he's trying to I kind of
was something like that
he was like we doesn't like and I
remember getting a call from my college
agent it was like they don't want to pay
you I was like what I do is not good it
was a safe you didn't make school laugh
and so they withheld your funds yes and
then another
terrible show is Keuka college which is
up upstate New York now real it's real
big colleges Keuka college and it was so
far and so cold I used to like five New
York and take my parents car and drive
all the way upstate New York to these
shows yeah and I was late because it was
in [ __ ] koukin New York and they're
like where are you and I was like where
are you I don't know maybe I'm in Narnia
I don't know where and then I got there
like I was very late to the show and
there's none like three people there and
they're like yeah I was like I need gas
money right now you need to pay me pay
me to leave cuca uh do you do any
colleges now I don't do any colleges now
would you ever I would yeah I think so
it's harder to relate now like it was
really interesting transition because I
was doing a lot of colleges and I start
doing a lot like comedy clubs and some
like just doing more that stuff and then
it was actually like it was a year that
I was like very long time ago when
Whitney Cummings had a sitcom and I was
like working on her show and it was
hiatus and someone called me like hey do
you want to do this show at this college
and I was like sure yeah and I went
there and it was supposed to be Krystal
II was supposed to perform and he pulled
out something like send the guy who
writes the show and then I got there and
I remember like looking at the crowd I
mean like oh my god these kids are
babies yeah it is it's very very
difficult I just keep seeing the words
tick-tock everywhere yeah have you
gotten into that are you kids into that
are they tick tock stars you know
they're too young to even be on the only
thing I've done well as a parent is like
we don't let them look at the iPad the
only thing everything else has been
[ __ ] one thing that we're like so they
he does it he likes to like do the snap
filter sometimes but but no I haven't
gotten take that should I or early to I
don't even know how I opened it and I
got really scared like this it was a
visceral reaction it just really it was
I've felt such empathy from my parents
opening YouTube for the first time and
what it must have been like for them
to try and navigate it and understand
why it exists in anyway yeah
and so yeah it just made me feel my age
which not necessarily the best thing
what is it just I'm not joking is it
just lip syncing two songs I've had many
people try to explain it to me I've
heard that there's a whole genre of like
Midwestern moms complaining about things
which I've heard it's fascinating but
also I guess gets really sad because
they think they're like really talking
to like an audience or two people and
those rock stars just tick tock stars
now that are basically like tweens I
feel like and it makes me a little
uncomfortable the same way like child
actors make me a little uncomfortable to
talk that's my 401 K is tick-tock
waiting for YouTube to really [ __ ] it up
and so I can make an actual move a
lateral move okay we're gonna take a
quick break when we get back I gotta
know you're a house hunters fan oh yeah
yeah we're gonna talk about all that
when we get back we're not too deep it's
that time to turn your dream into a
reality with Squarespace they make it
easier than ever to launch your passion
project do you want to start a new
business showcase your work published
content sell products or more
Squarespace is the tool for you they
have beautiful templates created by
world-class designers and the ability to
customize just about anything with a few
clicks so you can easily make a
beautiful website all by yourself they
also have a powerful ecommerce
functionality that lets you sell
anything online and analytics that help
you grow your site in real time
everything is optimized for mobile right
out of the box and there's nothing to
patch or upgrade ever buying domains is
simple and you can get the help you need
with their 24/7 award-winning customer
support they empower millions of people
from designers to lawyers artists to
gamers even restaurants and gyms to turn
great ideas into something real so head
to squarespace.com slash Grace for a
free trial and when you're ready to
launch use the offer code grace this
10% off your first purchase of a website
or domain that squarespace.com slash
grace offer code grace okay you love
house hunters yes I love all house
things okay your HGTV I am okay dude are
you like chip and Joanna Gaines I like
them are we gonna follow them to their
new network oh yeah what's the deal what
are they doing they're doing are they
doing reading their own network I feel
like they have the power did you know
they literally have started their own
network I know that they I mean I see
all of her products and target every
time I go yeah no they've left HGTV and
now they're full-on just doing their own
thing they're like producing like
episodes and episodes of shows I did go
to Waco Texas last are two years ago are
some things thank you and when you when
you drive in there's just a giant
billboard of chip and Joanna Gaines
saying welcome to Waco they changed the
whole place yeah it's like they're they
are the Czar's of Waco Texas now it's
bunkers to me yeah I love that me house
hunters for me was always a thing that
was fun but long rest in peace yes yeah
my brother grew up watching it would
always be a suicide Kwang loved it it
was so good and you know it just feels
like I wonder what the I feel like
they're shifting gears a little bit with
with what they with what people want to
see and what they do see I feel like you
know at least in LA it was always very
frustrating to watch those shows so it's
like you know two people were looking
for you know we're looking for like a 16
bedroom house 600 pools about just $25 I
like to watch the House Hunters
International or like the island hunters
have you ever seen that one yes people
that are shopping for islands it's
beyond my understanding of how T we
should work it's so insane I also don't
know I mean I'm so jealous of like
social media stuff I'm jealous of like
the island hunters are those people who
are just like we're gonna leave Idaho
and go to Switzerland
I'm nervous for you guys in this
transition and I don't think you're
gonna thrive there no I think it's like
no I really think leaving our five acre
farm studio apartment in Switzerland
with our nine kids can make our life
easier know what's going on yeah I also
just love imagining because you know I
watched so much reality TV and all that
junk that I have an understanding of
like the formula and the producing side
of it and how it works and just knowing
that they're clearly fed lines to say to
each other in like candid moments is my
favorite part of it that they're like
well house number two had that balcony
but it didn't have a garage like a
scripted scene and it's oh so
cringe-worthy and wonderful oh my god I
did it I did an HGTV like pilot that
didn't get picked up but it was
basically like I was I'm so into it so I
was like yeah I want to do is the house
show but then I realized like it's still
making a show okay and enter and action
I'm like oh there's production to this
production and you're right it's like
they have to produce the gas there to
get them excited to talk to them about
the things and even like the guests that
you even like cast they're still like I
think the windows I love it so much yeah
one guy was like I'm a door guy this was
this was the show that was my that I was
doing and he was like I'm a door guy and
I was like what it means like I just
care about the doors the most I was like
no no one does he's insane he's got an
each yes I'm not surprised they didn't
pick up the show up with me screaming
have you just kind of bullying people
into what why and why they shouldn't
like what they like and what's the
what's the show with the guy that ran
into the woods with a shotgun that was
the host and they broke up oh of course
time oh no tarik tarik Eric yeah that
was the whole drama now she's got a new
show yeah Kristine
the co-star say how we not think of the
name it's uh what is their show come on
Tariq it what is it called come on flip
or flop flip or flop
yeah yeah flip or flop and I think you
know he was always so intense on that
show that when all those stories came to
light I was like mm-hmm but HDTV was
like you know what TV show her getting
her life back together and also looking
for a home you know okay we got to go
back to your MTV days let's do it your
face or mine
yeah what is this show okay so you were
MTV host I was the MTV host like five
years I hosted MTV show called your face
or my in 2004 okay I wore different
glasses on every episode so it was
called your face or mine and we gave
away my pods and it was essentially hot
or not and it was it was a format owned
by Fremantle who produces American Idol
and it was a big show in the UK yeah it
was a British show hosted by Jimmy Carr
super funny guy so they brought it here
and then I hosted it and it was
basically I bring out you know someone
you know I bring out you and your
boyfriend right and I'd be like okay
boyfriend do you do you love grace yeah
lover do you think she's pretty is she
so pretty do you think she's prettier
than this girl sure yeah and he would be
like uh
[Music]
you know what note she's a mono she's
prettier than Grace and I go okay
audience vote like ah you're an [ __ ]
the audience think grace is prettier and
that was the show it was pretty bad but
but it was my first thing so I was
excited and and then we would like then
there was almost like a like a Jerry
Springer aspect really get one put like
the third round they'd sit down and I'd
be like do you think grace is prettier
than your ex-girlfriend right and then
he would be like no I think no no grace
oh she's the best
okay well Cindy come on out and what are
you thinking that she would come out and
then be like awkward and that was
actually pretty funny I honestly think
this show probably would do way better
today with like social media yeah it was
like pre social media there was
holograms it was totally crazy yeah this
feels like I mean I know there's that
Netflix show that's like hotter now or
100 percent hotter or something like
that there's some show about judging
people by their looks yeah it was a
pretty ridiculous show you seem like
you're comfortable with that intense
awkwardness yeah I can't do that like I
would be terrible at that I'd be like
let's talk it out you don't have to
choose yeah it was so weird because
there was also an audience and they were
like wow how long did that go for we did
24 episodes and we shot it in like five
days Wow then that aired it was well
those things was on MTV after TRL
500 times a day yeah and then after that
I hosted this show called the reality
show that was actually a really good
format - which was basically American
Idol for people who wanted reality shows
that wanted their own reality show the
reality shows so I was the host of that
okay and that was that was like a
competition show competition show and
there was Andy Dick was the judge and I
think Bam Margera was a judge mm 4 or 5
yeah I think Trishelle from real world
was a judge it was like wow
wait real-world like Vegas or something
yes yes you know how I pulled that out
of my rolodex in my brain that's nuts
yeah so it was basically that and and
that show was just that was not good
great show I mean a profound experience
that's an experience i anyone actually
get a reality show made after that I
think this one Italian kid from Staten
Island who was funny he had like a
grandpa so bred out of straw for some
for some time and then and then after
that I hosted the worst show which was
called pretty dumb I think which was
like a spring break show so I was just
sort of in the folds wow that must have
been quite an experience it really was
and I remember talking talking at Damien
Fahey because he was hosting TRL when
your facial I was on oh yeah I said they
used to always talk about how you can't
do that show singled out at least like
you know left some room yes there was
many people competing on that show this
show is just like you're ugly here's an
iPod is there a reality show
currently that you would go on oh I mean
I want to go on that Bishop show well
below deck I don't know what I do just
constant sex and fights but I just I
don't want to be around like I feel like
you and your family could be the Charter
guests now this oh my god I feel you
could make that happen
yeah below deck my family that would be
the funniest thing I know I watched that
show and I do sometimes fantasize and
like the voyeuristic way of like you
know if if the internet really goes
south I guess I could work on like oh
yeah even though I'm wildly
claustrophobic and don't like
interacting with people no I actually I
wanted to go on that show because it is
so ridiculous but I actually I went on a
Disney cruise this summer and it was the
law it was the longest time of my life I
can't do it was hard I was just like it
was just
I mean it's like going to Disneyland but
there's no rides and you can't leave
and it's very wavy wait is it the one
where like the characters show you up
and everyone's there so your kids must
have had a great time with you but it
was it was just hard for me to be on a
boat you know it's very rocky when I was
younger my the one like trip that my mom
and stepdad took me my brothers on was a
big red boat Disney Cruise and we had
learned immediately that my mom gets
seasick cuz like they sit you at tables
with like other families like to eat
dinner so they can feel like the you
know ten seat tables and at one point
that's like dad from this other family
just looked at my set that was like sir
your wife is and we looked over my mom
was just in the hallway on the ground
like clutching at the window on a cruise
you see a fly by - I was just basically
crushing drown me in XANA the whole trip
was like seven days I barely remember
adults
yeah how long did you go on it for it
was like it was seven days Wow Wow I
mean kudos to you a cruise is a big
commitment would you do it again no full
endorsement okay I heard you you are an
extrovert you love strangers yeah to the
point that you even like give your phone
number to strangers like on planes and
things like that yes have you had any
crazy like follow-up stories of like how
many people do you keep in contact with
on a regular basis well I basically this
is so foreign to me I'm very introverted
yeah so to hear that you just like
willingly are just like completely open
with complete strangers and my house it
was definitely more like in the in the
time of my life when I was traveling so
much that planes all the time and I
would as I talk to people and have
interesting conversations yes and the
one person who I really wanted to stay
in touch with was the I met I sat next
to the CEO of American Eagle which is
like American Airlines small planes okay
oh no not the clothing brand yeah yeah
[Laughter]
cool faded torn jeans for 20% off that
was all I wanted yeah so I was like I'll
discover my best friend and I emailed
him because I always would meet people
complains and then get their emails
email back and forth yeah for a while I
was talking with some guy who was like
in like I don't know he didn't work at
serious but he was like in like the
radio industry I mean like email back
and forth about like music which was
weird I've been a graphic designer
one time who like I then met in the
parking lot and and he then at coffee
bean and talked about Ben he designed my
website I guess I mean the parking lot
was a weird yeah I met him and then so I
got a website one time I talked to some
guy about radio one time I met a
musician I don't know I just a trainer
yes so you're really you are socially
networking without social media real
light in person I walk up to people and
I say like I like what you're doing
LinkedIn
please okay so you've been in a ton of
writers rooms yes what is a piece of
advice that you would give to aspiring
writers that don't really know what that
environment is like I guess you don't
need to talk that much yeah there's
really the key I feel like a lot of
times people like younger heirs are
nervous and you know everyone's
everyone's everyone no matter what level
they are yeah for executive staff writer
on a sitcom everyone always pretty much
thinks like oh did I say something
stupid yeah am I saying the right thing
yeah you know so I think a lot of times
people feel like they need to talk you
know because they want us like talk talk
talk and and pitch and I think like
that's sort of like the worst thing you
could do is pitch a lot and not score
and you're more likely to probably think
more it's just like kind of advice you'd
get sort of like as like a young kid
like yeah before you speak so I think a
lot of people don't need to do that much
to succeed in the writers room but I
think overdoing it will hurt you more
yeah no I listening I think listening
you're a big skill I remember my first
the first time I was in a sitcom
writers room was on
Whitney and they're a showrunner Betsy
Thomas who and I was friends with
Whitney I was on the show and I was
pretty comfortable and I was like you
know one of the only comics for the
first season so I was very used I was
sort of being a comedian before and then
getting it transitioning into writing
it's like a different sort of vibe
because I'm so used to like just talking
and setting really yelling jokes and
like not worrying about bombing really
right because you're kind of
workshopping like in an auditory way
like you're really working through some
stuff yes I'm like not that nervous
around a writers room because I've bond
in Keuka College nothing is gonna be
worse than Keuka College but I bet she
was like hey so I'm just wanted to give
you tell you I don't pitch so much okay
and I sort of took that advice and I
sort of you know carried that through
that's great yeah cuz I think people
assume that they have to bring stuff to
the table yeah all the time to show
their value or their worth in a
situation yeah and it's also you know
it's difficult those restrooms it's like
you have people who've been doing this
for like 25 years in these rooms you
people like heard every story or thought
of the joke or aren't thinking about the
joke right now or like you know so it's
just if there's so many different things
going on yeah that you know you that
you're not focused on I wasn't always
focus about like what's going on in
their head right right right yeah I've
talked to a lot of people lately about
like imposter syndrome that like rears
up for people constantly and just it's
kind of its kind of like satisfying in
some way to hear that so many people
like have those thoughts float through
their head of like I don't deserve to be
here so I need to prove my worth in so
many ways and it might come across you
know opposite of how you intend for it
to come across exactly so cool I think
that's really great advice also I did
you you got bit by a spider in the
writers room I did yeah what is this
story I know not not in the writers room
okay I believe this was what I was
working on the John Mulaney sitcom okay
I was oh no I've been bit my cheese man
I had a black widow problem I found out
Wow Scarlett Johansson kind yeah here's
the thing about me and my body is I am
very in tune with my body
so okay break a couple breaks oh so if
something is off yeah I immediately know
and people think of that as like a
hypochondriac but like I'm not because
I'm always right you just aware yeah
yeah for example right now I've had
shoulder pain for like months okay and
everyone like the Rose Room was like oh
you're just stress whatever you don't
know what's going on I was like no I'm
telling you like I'm in more pain yeah I
was like just stop just like say
something like no and then I went to the
doctor finally when I like my schedule
free and I was like you have frozen
shoulder and I was like oh that's a
thing is a thing it's mostly found in
elderly women women with diabetes but
[Laughter]
the frozen shoulder is a real thing what
do you do for that
physical therapy Wow so is it does it do
you get it because you're writing or
because your body is like leaning on
tables or laptops or things they don't
know it's it's it kind of basically it's
like a tightening of the shoulder
capsule mm-hmm so for example so you can
only raise your arm yeah that looks
pretty impressive did you heal me I
don't know you look like you're on a
roller coaster but you're you're like
range of motion is limited yes range
emotion is limited exactly so but anyway
so I I had like a little mark on my neck
and I was like I think that I was bit by
a spider I was like you know what you're
talking about telling you like something
is off so that I had my wife like circle
it that's when you invite everybody to
see if you attract oh you do yeah with
like a marker a little pen marker yeah
and then then I was like okay I got a
little pen I see if it tracks and then
like a couple hours later it did go up
and I was like I've been bit by a black
widow it's poison so they had to call my
wife called poison control Wow you guys
think you're supposed to and then
I was right I had everyone making fun of
me when I had a giant spider bite that
was like up and down by now Oh what do
you do for that antibiotics okay yeah
Wow but kudos to you for like knowing
how'd it like Boy Scout handle that like
draw a circle on my neck thank you for
understanding but this has happened more
than one spiders like my delicious skin
yeah I guess so that one broke down the
glass ceiling for them and so wow that's
very funny cuz I'm sure a lot of people
see it as like a neuroses that you're in
tune with how your body reacts to things
yeah I just think my body happens to
have a lot of things that happen do you
do any like woowoo la yoga meditation
acupuncture any of that kind of stuff
I've been meaning to meditate for like
ten years yeah I've had it for three
years notifying me at 10:00 a.m. every
morning that it's time to meditate and I
don't I haven't done it at all but I
know when it's 10:00 a.m. that's good
it's also like that app that says drink
water and you're like okay we're gonna
take one last break when we get back we
have a bunch of Twitter questions for
you so we're right back with more not
your date today we have support from a
company that wants to support you we're
talking about third love designed with
measurements from millions of women
third loves bra styles are made to fit
your life they have over 80 bra sizes
but know that only one is the one that
matters to you I have some third love
products and I can say from experience
they are supportive comfortable
absolutely wonderful it's hands-down the
most comfortable bra that you own they
have straps that don't slip
they have tag list labels and they have
lightweight memory foam cups that mold
to your shape plus returns and exchanges
are free and easy in fact thanks to
third loves perfect fit promise
every customer has 60 days to wear it
wash it and put it to the test if you
don't love it you can return it and
third love we'll wash it and donate it
to a woman in need third love knows
there's a perfect bra for everyone so
right now they're offering you guys 15%
off your first order go to third love
comm / grace now to find your perfect
fitting bra and get 15% off your first
purchase
that's third love comm / grace for 15%
off today the biggest risk in life is
not taking one and that's why Knowles
the National Outdoor Leadership School
empowers people to get outside where you
can find your purpose leadership style
and go beyond your comfort zone Knowles
believes in the wilderness and
experiencial learning the outdoors is
the best classroom in the world it was
founded in 1965 Knowles is the leader in
wilderness education serving over
350,000 students since it opened Knowles
offers adventure expeditions wilderness
medicine clinics and basic wilderness
safety courses students can choose from
16 campuses around the world where they
embark on extended wilderness adventures
ranging from one weekend duration to a
full year instructors teach outdoor
skills from backpacking to sea kayaking
to rock climbing and mountaineering in
the world's most spectacular mountain
ranges Knowles is known for its proven
leadership curriculum that teaches
personal leadership styles teamwork and
decision-making that can easily be
applied to everyday life their
wilderness education experience can
transform lives and if you want to get
started take advantage of 20% off your
next Knowles expedition go to Knowles
edu / grace that's nose and OLS edu /
grace offer expires February 29th 2020
terms and conditions apply find your
course today okay before we get into the
Twitter questions I'm gonna ask you the
two questions ask every single guest
that's on the podcast and the first is
who alive or dead would you most want to
throw cold spaghetti at oh yeah
live or dead I want to throw cold
spaghetti mm-hmm okay alive or dead
throwing cold spaghetti like a prank or
like because I'm mad at them it's
entirely up to you whatever your
intention is it can be joyous it can be
mean-spirited it
be a prank whatever you would like Bram
Lincoln okay and what kind of way would
this be thrown it's like okay the other
question every guest has to answer is to
tell us your worst pants shooting story
or a close call but you can only use
three words or three small phrases mmm
so mine for example is college jogging
front lawn okay yeah okay yeah okay okay
you know give me a close call it can be
whatever comes to mind
okay and there have been people that
have not had stories that they can tell
which blows my mind but you know what I
okay
last week the fresh story 24 Hour
Fitness Jamba Juice Wow Wow yeah you
know we're all trying to live or help
this lives in January it's hard yeah low
stress oh I bet poof sorry for that
Fitness okay let's get into these
questions Richard Cummings asked asked
about curtain call Inc yes we already
answered that yeah summer stock you guys
were the oh geez back in the theater
camp days hashtag not even embarrassed
I'm not even embarrassed I was rooster
in an e productions did you get an e we
did an E was the big one Oliver Oliver
what's funny about the Oliver show is
that I walked around that that auditions
being super cocky being like just so
everyone knows I'm gonna be Artful
Dodger I don't know why I was soaked I
wasn't very cool
he's a confident theater kid and they're
like okay and then I audition and I did
not even get cast in the show not even a
course did you work on the crew or
anything no would you do theater now no
no okay would you write theater oh yeah
I would write a play yeah yeah yeah I
think that would be fun yeah um Abraham
Lincoln his spaghetti mystery live on
Broadway that sounds like Joseph in the
tech magical Technicolor Dreamcoat
yeah I feel like the show sells itself I
wanna see what's on spaghetti cannons
I'm in some lets know if you could
change your last name to another piece
of water infrastructure what would you
change it to but they're pronouncing it
wrong I guess all right yeah it's it's
levy yeah not levy but I guess I would
ban pool yeah because that's a powerful
name I feel like you could sell cars
like save you know people from injustice
someone snow what tips you have for
organizing and managing writing product
projects lists lots of lists yeah yeah
yeah I got you got a make lists and I
always use red pens red pens red pens do
you hand write things still are you more
a laptop based person I write this all
the scripts laptop and then I will
rewrite and sort of proof and stuff with
red pens oh that's cool yeah so like
you're grading your own papers yes
terrible I thought you had potential and
they want to know also how do you
balance the variety of projects in your
life and keep yourself on track red pens
red pen and yeah how do you bounce
because you and your wife work together
yes right and the kids are involved here
and they're like how how do you guys
like go offline for lack of a better
word or like how do you guys log out and
like do relaxing like life stuff I would
love you gotta be nice to be able to
collaborate in a poem we work so well
it's the first time we've worked
together in a writers room and it was
cool it was so it was
so great and we the hardest part for us
was actually just like the just being
like a couple in a car you know can we
drive like 40 minutes to get the work
and just be like her telling me I'm a
bad driver and me no way yes and that
was the hardest part of working together
was we were in the room it was great
yeah and she sort of also like gets me
like she doesn't like calm me down in
sort of situations because it's so high
stress all the time you know there's
problems you really put out fires but
instead of being like it's okay let's
that she be like that is [ __ ] up you
should go in there right now do you
believe in chocolate milk for cereal or
only normal milk holy normal milk only
normal milk yeah
what's your go-to like guilty pleasure
food let's say guilty pleasure food is
skittles skittles yeah really a real
candy person but alright but not like
chocolate no I like likes our power
skittles warheads lollipops but okay I
ate so much candy when I was a kid that
as an adult I spent so much money fixing
my teeth stop with all candy like tooth
implants root canals Wow
yeah yeah it's too good do your kids get
candy baby boo they know that all my
teeth are fakes they can howl oween I
always just just [ __ ] fall off the
wagon so hard every house my dad's a
monster do you guys do like family
costumes for Halloween yeah well now
they're gay little bit older so we had a
we had a sort of break oddly this year
we were milk and cookies and then my
kids were like a spider-man and
something else oh that's sweet yeah
they're too cool to be associated yes to
get away from us like come on with your
crayons last year someone to know what's
the moment that makes you proud to be a
dad oh I guess the the most proud is as
a parent is when another parent or like
a teacher tells you how great your kid
is like he's so polite or he's such a
good listener you're like oh that's so
nice cuz that homey discreet Umi said
he's your daddy
that is the best oh that's great yeah
you're like thank God whew I can let
them into the real world and also they
want to know who is a person who has
deeply influenced your life a person
who's deeply influenced my life no
probably Laurie Gizeh who started
curtaincall Inc because she was the one
who started improv when I was you know
nine yeah very cool
and she was a huge fan of this podcast
so she'll love the mention nada has a
very important question is the purple
dick stain still on your driveway
good news everyone's the circle dick
stain is off we hear the context of us
questions so basically I there was a
marker on my driveway a purple marker
because I have kids and that's what kind
of happens you have kids [ __ ] out I
don't know i jus up the driveway and the
mark exploded I was like oh that's bad I
drove all the driveway later move the
marker and then there was a purple stain
on my driveway that look exactly a
purple dick like full-on dick and it was
crazy and I documented it and kept
trying to get off the driveway and
people it just wouldn't stop people
would become obsessed with a purple [ __ ]
I was getting all sorts of white power
wash it didn't work every version and
that purple dick is still there it's
still there still there wow I hope it
becomes part of like the celebrity tours
to the valley look to your left you'll
see the purple infamous purple dick
Keira wants to know can you describe
your friendship with Mulaney in three
words or three small phrases how long
have you guys known each other for a
very long time like early 2000s we met
doing comedy okay um we talked on the
phone like 14 year old girls and that's
how you describe your friendship I would
say I would say like we're all Jewish
men who communicate like 14 year old
girls but in the nineties because it's
mo it's like very long phone
conversations yeah do you guys have like
long-winded text threads yeah I imagine
yeah I feel like you could print those
out and make like a coffee table book of
it
take advantage of someone says ask what
he thinks Harry Styles would look like
without his hair terrible hair that guy
I know I feel like he's 90% is hair yes
what's your go-to music pop punk pop
punk green day rancid Operation Ivy get
her in there Eve six I went to EB six I
saw the last put this way the last two
collars I saw live Eve six and saves a
day Wow no you are living in a certain
area okay some wants to know which movie
would you like to unwatched so you could
feel the joy of watching it again for
the first time home alone home alone
yeah I just watched that I mean I've
watched it before but it's been years
and I watched it right around Christmas
and yeah perfect movie I also watch the
making of home alone it's great it's
great home below 2 though haven't seen
that one
what don't see it but then I saw it that
was like this isn't it I just oh no my
boyfriend I did start watching it I was
a little high and I just kept screaming
it's just bad parenting movie would be 1
minute long now doing the right parents
text them okay we're getting to in the
podcast I don't know what's coming up
like what's next what are projects that
might be in the works oh you can talk
about other I mean obviously the show
the show the show comes out February 6
that's the main main thing I'm gonna be
performing live stand-up the next couple
of months I'm doing I do a show called
open house yeah last night it was Largo
a few months ago basically I mean a
bunch of comedians look at listings on
ready fit in Zillow make fun houses oh
that's such a great idea so it's a very
fun show I was busy with making a sitcom
but now that that's once that's all
wrapped up and do that again in LA yeah
it'll be on my Instagram and also your
triumphant return to Twitter yeah with
long angry political to
is the one thing missing from Twitter
okay Dan before we wrap up every guess
it's on the podcast gets a personalized
fortune cookie from us to them so that
is for you from us it's I think in there
so okay here we go
oh okay opening it up here we go we know
you know the truth about Avril Lavigne
her replacement Melissa stop dodging
calls just tell us like it is yeah I
feel like you're in that I mean you live
in that era I do thank you so much for
knowing me so well you hold all the
secrets dan where can people find you
the show everything you're up to if they
don't know already and to make sure that
they don't get you confused with the
other gaggle of Dan levees and leave you
yes I am at Dan levy show and Instagram
dan levy at Twitter okay
the show is called indebted it's on NBC
February 6 there's it at indebted fan
page I would also just go on Fran
Drescher and Jessie Hodges and ovulated
Adam pally uh everyone's instagrams and
just watch the show sweet do it thank
you so much for being here this was so I
love this podcast go check out the show
guys and go follow him and you know
really hound him for those tweets that
we've been missing for years months
weeks days all of it we'll see you guys
next time one not too deep good bye bye
- deep toe deep deep deep not too deep
is a production of grace helbig
incorporated producer Melissa D months
edited by Shireen Loni Eunice
post-production sound by Chris Henry and
an extra special thanks to Flula for the
theme music
[Music]